Hello!
There is no music.
So quiet.
Why is it so quiet?
Why is there no music?
Tori, thanks for the raid.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Meido Minto.
Did you get water?
I did get water.
I got water.
Which I really needed because...
I think I had too much caffeine today.
Whoopsie.
Oh my gosh, wait.
That's me.
I did this.
This is like literally what I did last time.
Ducky, thanks for the gift card.
Oh, this is me.
Wait.
Yeah, I definitely didn't do that.
Oh, spoilers.
Wait a second.
No look, you know.
No look, no look, no look.
No, stop.
Oh, I did the dog.
I did the dog.
That's me.
Wait, no, I didn't do that part yet.
There is lizards.
Lizard men.
Oh boy, I'm getting all sort of spoiled today.
Oh, I don't... That was random.
Anyway, OK.
Welcome back to part 2 of...
May Cry!
Here, hold on.
Say the name.
I didn't time that at all.
Devil May Cry.
The enemy juggling was inspired by a glitch found in Onimusha Warlords.
Really?
Oh no, we are back to the fun facts.
This is the beginning.
The Devil May Cry bar place.
Mother and a brother.
Sparda.
Let's rock baby.
Oh, we are going outside?
Hold on, everything is happening.
Please, can we just go back to the menu?
Thank you.
I'm just going to click this.
We'll stay on this screen.
Because I can't speak when everything is going on.
Oh my gosh, jackpot.
Lizard men, the MC of your next book.
No, the next book is...
I can check.
But yeah, this is my first time playing Devil May Cry.
It's my first time playing the series.
I played it last week.
So we ended after mission 7.
No, mission...
We did more than mission 7.
Why is it saying...
Oh wait, return to the bedroom.
Oh no, we did mission 7.
Sorry.
I was like, wait a second, the bedroom.
I went there before.
So we did that.
Raven, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell if this is...
I can't tell if this is sarcasm or not.
I can't tell if this is a joke or not.
I got so many comments from people being like, did you know that this was supposed to be Resident Evil 4?
Oh god.
Wait, I can't tell if this is superchats.
I can't tell if you guys are being serious or not.
Wait, I can't tell.
Maybe I should hold on.
Let me make that the pin message.
Did you know...
That this was supposed to be Resident Evil 4?
Now you know.
Oh wait, I said now you know.
You know what, it's fine.
Now you know.
Oopsie.
Yes, I know.
But thank you for the reminder.
Thank you for the donos, I appreciate it.
Thanks for the tag, Gifter!
Now you know.
DMC stands for Damn MitoQ Stop.
Enjoy RE4.
Thank you.
I'm hoping I remember how to play the game.
Hopefully I remember how to play the game.
If I don't, if it takes me a minute to get back into it, please forgive me.
Did you know that this game features Dante from the Devil May Cry series?
Oh my gosh.
Featuring Dante from the Devil May Cry series?
Now you know.
We're surely going to be Jumpstart Adventures 3rd grade.
Do you plan to play 2 after this?
We'll see.
Maybe.
Thank you!
I better stay that way, Zachary.
I'm just kidding.
If it's your partner, you have to...
You have to...
You have to kami-oshi them, right?
I guess.
I don't know.
ViviCoin, thanks for the gift!
Skip in!
Real gamers don't skip too.
I just feel like I need to experience it.
You know?
If you press A right as the ball clicks shut, you increase capture percent.
Wait, what?
Oh, oh, this is Pokemon.
Featuring Dante from the Devil May Cry series came from SMT3.
I knew it was like some sticker on some game.
I could not remember what game it was though.
Okay.
Guys...
I don't remember the controls at all.
I will have to look them up again.
Oh, there's the controls in the menu, I believe.
We're on mission 7.
We just cleared mission 7.
We're on mission 8.
I have to remember how to pull my devil trigger.
I don't remember.
Is it under option?
No...
Here.
Oh...
Wait, what's the mission anyway?
Check your current mission.
What?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
This game was really released as Doki Doki Panic.
Cool, we have no mission.
Manual, probably.
Oh wait, let's go back to here.
I'm doing that thing where I press B instead of A because I'm used to Japanese controller setup.
Devil May Cry, but what about ghosts?
Ghosts never cry.
What are you talking about?
Actually, that's not true.
Ghosts cry all the time.
There's like ghosts that go like...
And there's ghosts that go...
You know?
This game will never be good.
It's Resident Evil.
It has no songs in the soundtrack.
It's been labeled by fans as clowns farting in the basement.
I love the Resident Evil basement song.
What are you talking about?
Oh here we go, here we go.
Devil Trigger!
Okay.
Aim...
Devil Trigger.
Show map?
What?
Wait, shoot?
Slash examine is B or X.
Action.
Okay, sword is Y.
Move.
Alistair select.
Does that mean like looking around?
What's type B?
You know what?
No, don't even look at type B.
I'm comfortable with where I am.
So Y, B, Y, B, Y, B, Y, B.
Y, B, Y, B, Y, B, Y, B.
Action.
Is that like jump?
Or an open door?
You haven't put enough ice monkeys.
Y, B, 2B or Y, B.
That is the question.
Okay.
Oh, I'm taunting?
Okay, this is taunt.
This is aim.
Devil Trigger which I just wasted, but don't worry about it.
It's fine.
Jump.
Sword.
We'll get it back.
It'll return.
Yeah, it recharges.
Y, B.
What if like we're right into a boss?
Oh, that's right!
I still haven't gotten that blue one down there.
The BORB.
I haven't been able to get that BORB.
The BLORB?
Press again to cancel Devil Trigger.
Oh, really?
Remember how to charge.
They got PP music and Devil May Cry.
I'm listening.
PP music and Devil May Cry?
No, wait.
I don't think so.
Do they?
Try wall jumping.
I tried.
Don't you think I'm just dumb?
Um...
Mission 8.
The legendary knight returns.
Activate the mechanism and escape from the rooftop.
I don't like the sound of that.
Whenever they say like escape from the blank blank it makes me sound...
It makes it seem like there's gonna be some time limit involved.
What's my power up situation looking like?
Way to have a lot actually.
Mr. Matt, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
We can get more BLORBS.
Fragment of Lot.
We can get another BLORB.
What was Alice's?
Oh, that's right.
Stinger.
How do I do the stinger again?
Plunge the sword from an even further distance.
It was like boop.
Why?
Why space why why?
I think.
Air hike?
Wasn't I saving up for something?
Maybe that's why.
Karuto!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Hideki Kamiya, the man responsible for Devil May Cry, would leave Capcom and go on to be one of the founders of Platinum Games.
One of the games Platinum was responsible for?
Metal Gear Rising Revengeance.
Aim forward and Y.
Lock on Y.
Saying thank you for all the fun streams.
Thank you!
Hold RB.
Press forward Y.
I think I was thinking of another combo.
I got this.
I'm gonna not buy anything right now then.
Back.
Exit.
Let's just, if I die, whatever.
Oh wait.
No, but my Yorbs.
I don't have any Yorbs.
I think we're fine.
Oh,
we're in a safe room.
How do I get up there?
Let's see.
I think I'm a genius, actually.
Oh, I had to do this anyway.
I'm not anything special.
Games not making me feel good about myself.
Wait, what's over here then?
Oh, got it, got it, got it.
Nice.
I'm a genius.
Yeah, Leon couldn't do that.
That guy sucked.
Why does this seem so ominous?
Hello?
Did I just see this in the beginning cutscene?
Oh gosh, this looks so ominous, you guys.
What the hell?
There's nothing here.
Here?
Oh no.
I just started the game.
What?
Again?
I've dealt with you like 15 times already.
You wanted to get nasty with me?
Game,
please.
I'm just not looking good.
Okay, fine.
This is taunt.
This is...
Oh my goodness.
Okay, okay.
Guys, I'll figure it out.
Don't worry.
Oh my gosh.
No, he figured out my stinger technique.
Don't do that.
Don't figure out my stinger technique, please.
Oh my gosh.
I hate you.
I didn't mean it.
Oh my gosh, stop.
My stinger is useless, you guys.
I gotta jump.
Get up on the Hydra's back.
Why are you shooting that way, dummy?
He's like doing no damage at all, actually.
Because he's like blocking his face, you little baby.
What are you shy?
You're so shy.
I'm dead.
Leave me alone.
Okay, so if I hit him in the face, he opens up.
I hit him in the face and he opened up.
He's just like peekaboo.
Okay.
You are dead.
Yeah, that's okay.
Alright.
Just like real life.
Me being dead.
There's nothing new for me, honestly.
Nothing new for me.
Mission start.
I don't think...
I noticed though like sometimes...
Like sometimes he would jump and like the glass would like...
I don't know.
There would be like glass that would break.
What was going on there?
This is a quick end if you can get him to jump on the glass.
Oh, there's a glass floor.
Oh, the one in the middle.
Oh,
this one.
Ah...
I see.
I'm sick of this guy.
Sick of this guy.
Okay.
I can't see anything.
Oh my gosh.
Why are these camera angles all of a sudden?
Please, I can't see anything.
I can't see anything.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, nevermind.
Up.
Oh, he shoots up at me too.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
And he like...
Nice.
Jump, jump, jump!
Oh my god.
Guys, I forgot how to shoot actually.
Oh, nevermind.
I remember how to shoot.
I can't see anything.
Ouch.
I keep pressing left trigger instead of double trigger.
You gotta live, buddy.
Oh my gosh.
I did not expect to go back into a...
Into a boss fight immediately.
We're getting like halfway there though.
We're getting...
Yeah, I know, for real.
What a warm up.
Oh, my double trigger was charged.
Oh, it charged really fast then.
I didn't realize.
My bad.
It's okay.
Double trigger came in last minute.
This is good though.
I think this is the best kind of warm up because it helps me...
Remember so much in like such a short amount of time.
You know what I mean?
Don't be afraid to spam double trigger.
Yeah.
I gotta really be better about it.
It charges faster each hit by melee.
I see, I see.
Scooby-doo.
Get up on the phantom's back.
How do I bait him to jump though?
Is it like I have to go far away?
I wonder.
He didn't jump very much this time.
Maybe I have to be...
Yeah, maybe I have to be further away.
Make sure to kill the boss instead of losing to the boss.
You're so right.
So true.
No, he doesn't start with a jump, right?
I think it depends.
Last time he...
Started with a charge.
Just like...
Do the thing.
Just...
Oh my god.
You're right!
Oh my gosh!
Oh shoot!
How the hell?
Oh, that cancels out.
That's nice.
I'm gonna...
Oh, I...
Damn it!
I keep pressing this.
I'm so sorry guys.
I know it's annoying.
It's annoying for me too.
Kill!
Oh my gosh.
Are
you gonna jump at me?
Or...
Oh!
Jump back!
I think
I cancelled it.
Nice.
Run!
Run Dante!
I'm believing!
I believe.
I believed!
I saw it kept recharging so fast.
Speed.
Nah, I'm like...
I'm mid-Phantom.
Sparda!
Good.
Oh my god, the way like the bloody magma is just spewing out of him is so awesome.
Sweet dreams!
Mommy!
Maybe.
Mommy?
I was gonna make a smartass comment, but you went and beat it before I had the chance.
See?
I just had to warm up a little bit.
Mommy!
Baby!
I just needed a chance to warm up.
Wait, can I go?
Oh, it won't let me go in there anymore.
Okay, let's keep going.
It's my birthday today!
Mike Tyson's!
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
It's your birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
What's that?
The legendary pitchfork.
Trident.
A heavily decorated three-pronged pike that's used for rituals.
It cannot be used as a weapon.
Lame!
Hello?
Why is some of this... What is this little courtyard area?
This castle is weird.
DMC.
What's up here?
It looks like there's something up here.
No?
Okay.
Jump on the whore... Just kidding!
I knew it!
I knew...
Are you so serious right now?
Okay, good, good.
There
we go.
Oh shoot.
I saw it up there.
I was like, I can get it.
Fancy jumping there.
Wait, if I jump on the other horse's head do I get more rorbs?
Rorbs, please.
We got a piece of blorb.
And we got some rorbs.
No, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, now... Oh, Dante, no.
Dante, there we go.
What's this?
It's a lever used to wind up the drawbridge.
It's heavily rusted.
A strong downward force may help move the lever.
Okay, let me check out the rest of the room first.
It's the corpse of a soldier who must have wandered into the castle and died from exhaustion.
Same.
He's holding something.
A grenade gun!
Oh my gosh!
Fires exploding shells of shrapnel.
Extremely destructive.
Yes.
It seems to be a little slow.
Oh my gosh, my health.
I just realized.
Hopefully it will be okay.
Oh, sorry.
Once again, confusing things.
Can I open this up?
There must be a way to open this.
Yeah, just with your hands.
Mint.
Made me mint.
Would you rather fight one phantom-sized phantom or a hundred phantom-sized phantoms?
Are you saying...
I did it.
I'm already at war with myself, please.
Oh...
How silly.
Today I turned 31!
Can you please put in a good word for me with the afterlife?
I would appreciate it.
John, you still have way more time before the afterlife.
But I will try.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, John V.
Can I try... Wait a second, we've been in this room before.
I have.
There are three openings to insert something.
Shall I use the trident?
Yes.
That's what I meant by three openings.
The devil may care.
Your progress as a devil hunter...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's slowly but surely.
Slowly but surely.
Getting down.
Ok, there we go.
And one more.
There you go.
Oh, and it still goes.
Am I supposed to...
Oh, ok.
Was I supposed to...
Oh my god.
Was I supposed to make it downstairs before that closed?
Now that I'm wondering.
You need to race it.
No way.
I just realized.
I was like, why is it going so slow?
It said this gun is very destructive.
It worked.
It did not work.
Wait, so how do I get it back up again?
And how...do I...get...oh my gosh.
Stop it!
Work.
You can come up with Inches Will Laugh as a parody title, but it actually sounds cool AF.
B, that's what I'm pressing.
Oh, there we go.
Yes, yes, please.
Oh my gosh.
Jump.
There we go.
Run.
Just go.
Just go for it.
Dante, go!
Ignore everybody else!
Is there here?
Oh, I made it.
I made it!
Welcome to my workshop.
Thank you.
I think my head almost got cut off there.
Actually a little bit, but you know.
C for cry.
Devil may cry.
Also, C's get degrees, baby.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, no.
We're good.
Next mission.
Mission 9.
New strength.
Use the new strength to open the door.
I'm stronger now.
I'm stronger.
Oh, there is the drawbridge.
I wish the camera angle would let me see the whole castle, you know.
There is a message carved in the circle.
The wheel of destiny shall guide you to the land of the beginning.
Also, I just realized.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Part of the game is cut off.
I'm so sorry.
I thought it was going to be 4-3 the whole time.
Here, I'll shrink myself just a tad.
There we go.
Sorry, I didn't notice sooner.
I thought it was 4-3 the whole time.
Good thing we made it in time.
OK.
Is this another boss battle?
I just did one.
There is a message carved on the stone.
It's a riddle of some kind.
There are secret dimensions where red stones hide.
They will appear when you do the out of the ordinary.
Oh, I thought it was going to rhyme.
OK.
Here I am putting on my stupid...
Why?
Riddles are supposed to sound a little funky, you know.
They are supposed to rhyme and stuff.
It's supposed to... What's out of the ordinary?
When I do this.
Nobody does that.
Also, this is a safe area, I guess.
We have this guy.
When I jump on top of here.
Oh, when I jump on top of here.
Oh, when I jump on top of here and make it.
It kind of rhymed.
No, it didn't.
Hide in ordinary?
Cody?
Cody, are you OK?
This is the out of the ordinary.
Oh wait, I can taunt when I use my right analog stick too?
That's funny.
What about here?
Oh, please.
Can I get the other... Oh, there is one over here too.
Flat.
Wait, what does this say?
Quick note about DMC.
It doesn't fully grasp its identity until DMC3.
So the jump in quality between 1 and 3 is huge.
I hope you can get to it eventually.
I will!
Thank you!
That's usually always why I play in release order.
Joy, thank you so much!
Anything rhymes if you say it hard enough.
That's usually why I play in release order because...
It's just way too... It's just not as fun of an experience if you have to go from such a well...
A game that has been released way later and has finessed the controls to a game that just came out and everything.
You know.
So, when I saw some people being like, she's playing...
She's playing 1 first.
Why?
Because...
That's, you know...
If I can master the controls here, then, you know...
Then it's... The idea is that... Oh, come on, please.
The idea is I'll be better at it when it gets to further games.
I should be the one that fills your heart with light.
I don't think I understand that yet, but thank you.
But yeah, I...
I have heard so much from everybody about playing DMC2 or playing in release order.
Please.
Or that this game was supposed to be Resident Evil 4.
I'm so tired.
Please.
Like the purple Chibi Minty.
Thank you.
Oh, there's a message carved in the stone.
Seems to be a story of some kind.
Destiny awaits somewhere deep in the Coliseum.
That is not... What's... Where's the story?
What are you talking about?
That was one sentence.
Here we go.
A grorb.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, it scared the heck out of me.
Oh my god.
I'll grab those.
Thank you.
I killed him.
I think.
I did it.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here.
A yorb.
Sacred stone brings... What?
Oh my gosh.
A yorb!
Remember me?
I told you you'd be annihilated.
Get the rorb.
Wait, what?
Yay!
I can save now.
I know.
Oh my gosh.
Hallelujah.
Wait, is there stuff up here?
This looks like a little secret area.
What's this?
There's a message carved into the giant stone tablet.
This is where blue light is sealed.
Well, I'll unseal it.
Yay!
Blorb.
Nice.
I'll take that blorb.
Thank you.
There was more over here.
Dante is running extra slow in this area.
Why?
Wow, there's so much around here actually.
Why do these feel like traps?
I'm kind of scared.
If you side roll in between each shot you can fire the grenade launcher faster.
I see.
Some more relevant questions.
Do you know about the Divine Comedy?
I don't.
There's a decoration resembling two knights.
It appears as though the knights should be holding something.
Words are carved beneath the decoration.
The shields that glow with light and a pair of lances shall lead to the battleground.
Wow, there's so much.
Oh my god.
There's so much here.
This looks like a glowing shield.
There's an emblem of a shield on the door.
Why does this door look so tiny?
It's made for babies.
Oh, with red light.
Sorry.
Oh, I guess Dante is the baby.
It's literally the size of him.
Nice.
Don't say Minto size.
Wow, there's so much...
Oh my gosh, there's so much around here you guys.
What's this?
I got...
Holy water!
Water of divine blessings.
It holds the power to eliminate all the evil that's around you.
Ooh...
Dante is canon 6'3"?
I was gonna say, he's actually as tall as these doors, so I feel like they're...
I feel like... I thought they were all just very small.
OK, so we have this area, we have this area, and then we have this whole hallway.
So let's go down the hallway, I suppose.
Grab all these orbs.
Oh wait, there's another...
There's an emblem of a shield on the door that glows with blue light.
Did you know that Dante and Leon were supposed to partake in hot, steamy...
Oh look, I reached my word limit.
Thanks, Alex.
Didn't know that.
Hot, steamy what, Alex?
Hot, steamy what?
So what did it say again?
Hold on.
The shields that glow with light and a pair of lances shall lead to the battleground.
OK, so we need both shields and then also...
Oh, this is the coliseum that we're at.
And then we need the lances.
Words are carved here.
Oh, a pair of flames that dwell with strength will open the path.
Dante is canonically 6'3".
Forget saving the world.
His eyes should be playing for the 76ers.
Why does this look jumpable?
Anything?
I don't see anything.
I guess we're going down here.
Down yonder.
Alright.
Here we go.
Am I going to get ambushed again?
This gate must have led to the outside, but it's been destroyed.
And that means I can't go through.
Astute observation, Dante.
I don't need ladders.
I don't need your stinking ladders.
Let's see.
Good morning, Minto.
Good morning, Minto!
What's this?
It is a star.
Devil star.
Crystal with magical powers that will recover five devil trigger gauges.
Let's go.
Check out the other side.
I did see the thing in the middle.
I don't need no ladder.
The blue and the...oh, there we go.
Yorb.
What's this?
Oh, this is the thing that I hit.
Before we do that, I saw a yorb.
Over yonder.
That's not a yorb.
Oh, it is a yorb.
Now we have two of them.
Lucky us.
Lucky, lucky.
What was over here though?
Oh, I'm an idiot.
It's all connected.
Oh my gosh.
Devil may cry parkour.
Oh boy.
OK.
This is fine.
No!
I thought I'd cheat the system.
Oh gosh.
Literally impossible.
This is...the camera angles make this so...
God!
Oh no.
OK.
Welcome to the hardest part of the game, Rinto.
This one and the one in DMC3 are the worst.
Oh, my depth perception will not allow me to do this properly, I think.
OK.
Oh man, I can't tell how far I am at all.
I feel like I should be able to make it to this one even too, right?
Like...hold on.
OK, I'm gonna give up.
Not on the entire segment, just trying that.
No one jumps for the blorb.
I've been sent to DMC parkour civilization jail so many times now.
Oh my gosh, I barely make that.
OK.
Once we go back up...
Oh my gosh.
Guys?
I was so close.
Is this all just for a yorb?
Or is there actually something that I need to...
Well, what is that up there?
Oh no, that's something floating.
OK, I do need to get that.
OK.
That was close.
It's a thing.
Yeah, it's a thing.
OK.
Alright, camera angle.
Good job.
OK.
Alright.
That was close.
OK.
Nice, nice,
nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice!
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I might be...I might be the parkour champion!
I might be the parkour champion!
It's an inscription.
Oh there is an inscription on the base.
My name is Ifrit.
The fool who awakens me shall pay dearly with the fires of hell.
OK.
Guess I'll wake you up.
Wait, I'm absorbing the power?
Wait, I'm kind of ISO?
A flaming gauntlet that gives the possessor increased powers!
Oh my gosh, am I a punchy guy now?
Devil Arms.
Wait.
But...
Oh, but...wait.
What about Alistair?
Wait, should I keep Ifrit or Alistair?
Ifrit my beloved, the power of rising dragon.
You can quickly switch to...with right stick?
Oh, let's try it.
Hold on.
OK, it's not super fast, but it is quite fast.
Oh nice.
Is that it?
I think I...I'm going to guess there is something over here.
There is nothing over there.
Oh gosh!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Judge!
Oh, I miss?
I miss my sword!
Oh, well...
I did miss it and I changed to it.
I miss having the range.
Home, home on the range.
That doesn't seem very good.
Oh this doesn't...
Oh my god!
This seems a little bad, I think.
Maybe I should have saved.
Darkness Mundus?
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you just...wait.
This might be stupid, but I think I should do this.
Okay, we are on file 2.
I just taunted him on accident.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the Hocus Pocus!
I can't...I can't pay attention right now!
Your timing is...
Oh
my gosh!
Ouch!
Oh I tried to jump!
I tried to jump!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Sometimes you jump, sometimes you don't.
Jump!
Dante!
Get out of the way!
I don't know if I'm actually supposed to...maybe...
Okay, what do I have?
Do I have my...
Oh my god!
Don't jump!
Sometimes jump!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Oh, devil trigger.
Let's do that.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh!
At least I healed.
Oh my god!
Ouch!
Yeah!
Oh gosh!
I don't think I'm doing this fight correctly, but whatever.
Yeah!
Oh gosh!
Oh!
Ah!
Shoot!
I didn't see it.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die, I think.
Ah!
No!
Oh my god!
I think I'm dead.
Try again.
Oh wait.
Guys, if I run out of orbs I'm so doomed.
What?
Why are we here?
Wait, why is it you guys?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Oh shoot.
More?
Oh.
Get away from me.
Oh my gosh!
Why is he not stopping?
I'm gonna run out of orbs at this point.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell is this camera angle?
Thank you.
No!
I lost a big orb.
It's so rude.
I'm gonna run out of orbs.
If they make me always go back to this part.
Lost a big orb.
Yeah.
Ok.
Oh shoot.
Alright.
I wish there was a level up thingy here because I kinda wanna wish... I wish I had more air...
What was... Wait.
I don't even know if I can afford the air one.
I think it was 4000.
Can't even afford it.
Ok.
Alright.
Let's do this.
Wait.
Air rate is 750?
What was the other one that I'm thinking of?
I can't see anything!
Oh shoot!
Why did I jump early?
Oh my gosh.
Oh that was so close!
Oh shoot!
Double trigger.
I'm just gonna double trigger whenever I can.
Oh.
That was kinda silly.
That was pretty silly actually.
Please.
Oh my god.
Why is it... Why... What is happening?
I hate this camera angle so much.
Don't move!
Why am I not hitting him ever?
I have an itch on my nose.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh game.
Please.
I know you hate me.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no, no, no.
Please.
Please god.
I can't see anything.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
We are so close.
Nice.
Second try.
Flock off feather face!
Save complete.
Alright, then we go this way.
Minto kinda cracked.
Oh wait.
Pair of flames that dwell with strength.
Do I have to like punch it?
Do I double trigger on it?
Can you... Big puncha.
Oh, here we go.
Wait, I didn't even know I could do that.
Wait.
Oh, I see.
I see.
There we go.
Back to my sword I feel very comfortable with.
I feel like Silent Hill out here.
There is something in this tree.
Spoopy area.
Rorb!
I mean, sorry.
Grorb.
I don't know my colors.
I always just want to say Rorb I think.
Uh oh.
What does that mean?
Oh no.
Why?
Please.
I just had to deal with a big old bird.
No!
Why are you here?
What is that?
Oh gosh.
God, why?
Fetish?
I'm
not really concerned about killing it coolly.
I'm concerned about living.
Wait, there was a big old Rorb there.
Take that.
Oh!
And explode!
And attack!
And jump!
Jump and explode!
And attack and explode!
I saw a Grorb!
I see a Grorb!
Oh, I got him.
Jump!
I love fight and explode.
It's maybe not the most stylish, but it's effective.
Maybe the game says that's not how you are supposed to play my game.
I don't care.
It's effective.
Wait, what about this over here?
This also had it's own little...
What's in here?
I don't want to... I don't know.
I heard some walk... Oh come on!
Leave an area.
There's always gotta be new buddies here.
Get away from me!
I guess I'll go here first.
Mr...
What's this?
Safety room!
Safety room.
Magma drive.
Charge power and release it in the form of a magma uppercut.
Kirk?
Oh, kick this.
Sorry, I couldn't read the font on the left.
I was like, who the hell is Kirk?
Kick 13, level 1.
Kick is smooth.
A quick but powerful flaming back roundhouse kick.
It's impact will drive the enemy back.
Rolling blaze.
Surround the body in flame and damage enemies upon contact.
Meteor level 1.
Shoot fireballs from the fist.
Inferno.
Create a wall of fire and burn everything within range.
Do not have enough orbs.
I really like Stinger though.
There's what?
Air raid?
Become airborne and become capable.
Yeah, air hike is the double jump.
Stinger is live.
I love Stinger.
I don't mind this one, it's just I feel safe with so much range.
Guys,
it's so confusing!
It's so confusing when you go from...
From Japanese games where X is back and circle is submit.
And then you have to do circle, submit, X back...
Wait, no, hold on.
Wait, X...
Yes, circle no.
Oh my gosh.
No, I didn't mean to do this.
I didn't mean to do that.
Wait, so how do I use it anyway then?
What did I even buy?
What did I buy?
Weeb problems.
I know, I know it's a weeb problem.
What did I buy anyway?
Charge power and release... Oh, I'm never gonna use this!
How long of a charge is it?
Lock on, back attack.
Oh, I'm never gonna use this.
I'm never gonna use this.
What do you mean back?
Oh, not... Wait, yeah, controller setup.
Wait, that doesn't show me anything.
Six months with the Minto.
Thanks Viper!
See, it's so easy to just click forward, you know.
Oh man...
The opposite direction that Dante is facing.
I can't believe I wasted my robes.
I'm so angry.
Wait, so let's see what down here is.
Oh,
I'm so sorry!
Wait, unlock 50% of all entries for every enemy file.
That's an achievement I just got.
There's like 50 of you.
No,
no, I want to attack the other guy.
Don't even let them stand up!
Not
interesting, not fun.
Not interesting or fun.
Stupid move.
Terrible.
You're the worst at this game.
My sick reflexes, everybody.
How do they... When do they stop?
We are farming robes like crazy right now.
I guess that's when they stop.
Holy moly!
Yorb!
Beloved Yorb!
Please, Dante, stick the landing.
Ah!
Something endearing about a maid running around with a grenade launcher, stingering you on the door, and blasting your mid-range while your ass is on the floor.
I'll do that to ya!
I will.
What's this?
Devil star.
What is this though?
Oh, this is a...
Yes!
Farm the robes!
Yeah, baby!
Two attacks delay.
What is that sound?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, where did you come from?
What?
Wait.
Two...oh.
Where the heck?
Big money.
Hell yeah.
Wait, is there anything in here?
A grorb and a little bit of orb.
What's this?
You use...
I don't always have trouble with confirm and cancel.
I always swap A, B, O, B.
Keep it the same across all games.
I much prefer JP style.
It makes sense.
The JP style, because it's like circle is OK and X is no.
I keep spending my robes, you guys.
Wait a second though.
Where am I supposed to go?
I guess I'll go through here.
Oh!
Bird of prey.
Survive an encounter with a griffon.
OK.
But X marks the spot.
No, X is like no.
Like bad X.
But O is like ping pong.
OK.
I wonder if the other...
If the other...
If I swapped controller style, if it would be better.
Snake might say I can't do it when it comes to singers, but Dante doesn't have that problem.
So true.
Next mission.
Canyon of mist.
Come out of the labyrinth canyon alive.
Easier said than done, man.
Just live.
Just do it.
Should I get another blorb?
Finally made it to a stream.
Hello!
Just live.
Should I get another blorb?
Blorb.
Buy all blorb and plorb.
I'm going to
buy a blorb.
I know I said I was saving up my money, but I've already wasted it.
I've already wasted it on this.
I know people were saying this too though.
You know what?
How do I do the kick if I want to use it?
Hail to the blorb!
How do I use the kick?
It's like stinger?
Same way as stinger?
Hi dad!
Alright, that's as much as I'll spend now.
Canyon of mist.
Mission start!
I'll even put my fists up.
That's it?
Oh I kicked.
Yeah.
But I like that with the stinger.
It gives you a lot of range.
You start in there real well.
These guys are not even subtle about it.
We did it.
Oh, there's more?
Somewhere.
Where?
Oh, down there.
What's it say?
It's a riddle of some kind.
Valley of the mist.
One must choose the right path...
to enter the lost land.
Only those who protect the weak...
Light shall have the power to decipher the right path?
Wait, what?
Worst riddle ever.
What the hell was that?
Am I gonna hate this?
Am I gonna hate this mission?
Have you had work today?
Oh no!
Good luck with work!
Oh, ouchie ouch.
Oh my god, they never... Oh wait, it's this little light thing.
Is it this?
This little guy that I'm watching run away from me?
It's that little guy.
Oh my god!
Oh, you again!
OK.
Where'd my little light friend go?
Oh, there he is.
OK, let's just keep running.
OK, following you!
Come on, guy!
OK.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, where'd my little worm go?
I mean my warp go.
Where is he?
Little guy!
There he is.
Is it the same way every time?
OK, I'm following you!
OK.
Oh!
Oh my god, what am I facing?
No!
No, you are not serious right now.
You are not serious right now.
Oh my god.
Please, let me away from this area.
Thank you.
It's just a mini guy.
Ouch.
I'm gonna...
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, there is another one.
OK, very good.
OK, I love that.
I love fighting this guy.
This tiny bit over and over.
There we go.
Tiny little guy.
Yep, yep.
Very good.
Love that.
Oh, nice.
They are kicking your butt.
Are they?
You wanna say that again?
Huh?
They are kicking my butt?
Yeah, you wanna say that again?
Huh?
Kicking my butt, huh?
I...Oh yeah, I keep forgetting that I can cancel the...
I guess I didn't need to grab that, huh?
My health is full.
I keep forgetting that I can cancel the devil trigger, but it's OK.
Let's see.
Anything up here?
Besides a hot lady head.
OK, this is kicking my butt.
I just get so flustered.
Climbing onto the woman.
I'll make it.
Maybe I won't.
You know what?
I give up.
This one is glowing.
Why?
The devil may cry because his Oshimito hates him.
No!
OK, I don't think these have anything.
OK.
Let's continue onwards.
What was the mission anyway?
Come out of the labyrinth canyon alive.
Oh, I think we made it.
Yippee!
B for Binto.
Nice.
I'll take it.
And I will save.
There we go.
Binto.
Boobies.
No!
What mission am I on now?
I don't even know.
Oh, 11.
What, there were 25?
26?
Offer the chalice and open the path.
23!
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, wait.
We are almost halfway there.
Yippee!
Oh, what is that?
What is that?
Oh my gosh, what is happening?
What is happening to me?
They are playing...
They are playing like...
With my body.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell is this guy's issue?
Oh my god.
No, I hate this thing.
I hate this thing a lot.
He is too fast for me.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, stop, stop.
Stop playing with my body, please.
Stop!
Stop it!
I can only...
Oh my gosh.
Please.
This area sucks so bad.
This area is really terrible.
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
Where are you?
I was killing him for a second.
No, stop!
Ouch!
I don't like this guy.
No!
I'm not hitting.
Oh my gosh.
It's so annoying.
Because when he is in this mode, I don't know what to do with him.
Ok, there we go.
I feel like I'm just jumping around and doing nothing.
Oh no, no, no, no.
What just happened?
Oh my god!
I escaped I think.
Oh, I think he is dead.
Wait, I thought areas with this thing were safe areas.
I guess not.
Oh, what's this?
What the?
What's going on?
Did I die?
Oops.
I died, I think.
Wait, I didn't want to use my YORB!
But if I...
I used my YORB.
You could reload.
I could, right?
Wait.
If I just exit and then...
Wait, I did reload right at the beginning of this mission, right?
So, ok.
Because it's like, what's the point in using the YORB?
Oh, I did it again.
Oops.
Oh, it's just... Wait, how do I actually reload?
Ok, hold on.
In here?
Exit?
No.
Reset?
Quit the mission?
Yes.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Load.
You.
Ok, the chalice.
Yeah.
Do I still have my...
I don't know how much...
Ok, I think it's... Yeah, I used...
Ok, we're good.
We're good.
Those have been bought.
Mission start.
And now, I'm gonna see... Ok, I still have two YORBS.
We're good.
You guys, please.
I don't know if you guys are being joking or sarcastic anymore, but please know more about the Resident Evil 4.
Please.
Please save me.
You can use holy water against enemies you don't like.
You know what?
That's so true.
Please, I'm so sick about Resident Evil 4.
I'm gonna become a Resident Evil 4 auntie.
It's not a joke.
It's a piece of fun trivia.
Oh, maybe I need to update the pin message then.
Maybe.
Please.
I know.
I've never been more annoyed by people trying to give me a fact before.
I've never become more annoyed by people.
Just always...
Ok.
I'm gonna holy water this guy.
Wait, how do I use it?
Use it!
Is that it?
Is it done-zo?
No!
I didn't use it.
Oh, you have to use it close enough.
Oh my god.
No way.
Ok.
Or...
I think it has a range.
Of course.
Please.
Oh, I accidentally jumped into the hole.
An accident or a blessing in disguise.
Accident or blessing in disguise.
Don't go in there.
It's a trap.
It's not worth it.
Ok.
I really can't.
I can't really.
I'm not gonna buy anything though.
I just wanted a little break.
I just wanted a break from this guy.
I hate him.
Ok.
So, if I use it...
Like when he's right next to me.
Like now.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
It worked!
Yippee!
Yay!
Wait, what just broke?
What was that sound?
Who just arrived?
Who's here?
There's an inscription.
Those without the sign are not worthy to possess the chalice.
Walk the dark path towards the light of sorrow.
The sign is confined in the cage of doom.
Ok.
Oh.
Maybe...
Oh, maybe it wasn't the sound of something breaking.
Maybe it was the sound of...
How do I get the blorb?
And the grorb.
Ok.
I thought it was the sound of like glass breaking, but I think it's just my steppy steps.
This way.
Ok.
There's a lot going on in here.
Can I... Can you grab that?
Do I need to double jump here?
Alistair's jump attack was also a good choice for that enemy.
The one I don't have.
Yeah.
Some of this stuff is expensive.
What's this?
Oh!
Another devil star.
Let's go.
Ok.
Tiny rorb.
Over here.
More rorb.
Can I like...
Oh dang.
I thought I could break the glass.
How do I get inside?
Not RE4 DMC fact.
DMC2 Dante is featured in...
Yeah.
I know that too.
Ok.
Maybe...
Let's see.
Oh!
Is there anything that looks breakable?
Anything that looks breakable?
See like this glass looks broken.
Just get through there Dante.
You're dumpy.
He's too...
Too thick.
I think.
How about a compromise?
We just give Minto a break from any Devil May Cry facts today.
For the rest of the day.
How about we do that?
For my own sanity's sake.
If you guys don't mind.
Oh my goodness.
Wait.
This looks...
There we go!
One full blorb!
Yippee!
And then there was a green.
But I guess I... Do I need the green?
What's my health at?
Oh we're fine actually.
We don't have to get the other one.
The other grorb.
How do I... How do I get out?
It was just right over here though, right?
I don't like leaving things behind.
It's like... Even if I don't need it, you know?
It's like the...
The loot goblin in me.
Blade Kai!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Let's see.
Them graphics.
Aw yeah!
Wait, so is there a little area that I can jump in here?
Doesn't seem like it.
How do I get in?
Guys, I need that item.
I need it right now.
I need it!
I need that item.
Go underground.
Below?
Oh I see!
Wait.
Not comboing very well right now.
Oh no.
Oh wait, I forgot that I can change it.
Devil trigger for regular enemies.
You're so true.
You're so right.
Actually, that's so right.
DEVIL TRIGGER!
Oh, who am I shooting at?
I don't know.
It's that guy.
Destroy.
More fragments!
Rorbs!
And more...and more rorbs.
And more blue fragments?
Or what is this?
Sign of chastity.
Dante...
He's so busy fighting demons, he's got nothing else to do.
I mean rather, he's got no time for anything else.
A taxidermic organ coated by crystal.
Within it is the sign of chastity that's necessary for searching the chalice.
We did it!
Wait.
Oh wait.
I knew, I knew, I knew you all would be back.
I knew you all would be back!
Perform an S-Rank combo!
Guys, I might be good at this game.
I might be good at this game.
Just saying.
Wait, is this guy still down here?
No, we're okay.
I was gonna say there's nobody down here, right?
I hate that guy that I had to fight before.
I do not want to fight him again.
I really...Oh, I have to get these.
I need the rorbs.
I need them, I need them.
Wait.
Oh, there's a platform up here.
Let's try this.
I need them, I need them, I need them, I need them.
Oh, what's going on?
Nice.
Okay, we got one.
The camera was just like...
Wait.
One more time!
Got it.
Okay.
Which door is it?
Is it this one up here?
I guess we shall see.
Before though.
Serve complete.
Wow, I love being able to tell what's in here.
Is Minty fresh?
Yes, actually.
Extremely.
I don't care what's behind door number...2!
Is this just downstairs from where I was before?
I think so.
Oh, that's the chalice.
And that's a rorb.
Wait, where did I just jump to?
How did I do that?
Wait, oh.
Oh, my bad.
This looks like a boss area, I think.
This looks like a boss area.
I feel like every room is a boss area at this point.
There's a cup on the base.
Protected by a powerful light.
Prove yourself worthy with the sign.
Should use the sign of chastity?
Yeah.
I have no brain.
It's a real egg.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Chalice, the cup which held the blood of the divine dead.
Delicious...
That's gonna...
What's happening?
Sparta?
Retro.
Wait.
Am I gonna have to fight you?
Can I have my sword back?
Oh my gosh.
I will.
I will use my...
Gun on you too.
Jump.
Oh my gosh, I wasn't aiming.
So I'm stupid.
Oh my gosh, he hits so crazy.
Holy moly.
Oh my gosh, he hits so crazy though.
Shoot.
And I even took my devil star.
I took it.
So rude.
Even though I have everything else, but I took my devil star.
I wonder if I... Should I use my sword here instead?
I wonder.
Wait a second, I think I missed...
Oh Johnny, thank you so much for the memberships.
I totally missed that earlier.
Thank you.
Wait, there we go.
There are some heals in the area.
Are these heals?
No, they are just decoration.
Let's see, what's in the...
Ok, so down here...
We can come down here for some grorb.
Delicious.
Everybody needs a grorb.
And they are balanced.
Oh, there is one single grorb.
I wish
I didn't take my star.
I'm so salty about that.
Ah...
Ok.
Oh my gosh, he hits so hard.
Stinger!
Get stinger!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Jump.
Double... Wait.
Hold on, there we go.
I kept trying, but...
Time for... Oh my gosh, that was such a good timing.
Wait, I can't... There we go.
Where is he?
Hello?
Excuse me.
I can't suck!
I suck!
No!
Can you come down here or...
Oh my gosh, what is he doing?
What are you doing?
Wait, why am I in phase 2?
I didn't even...
I got further.
I got further before, but now he is like doing combos and stuff that...
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Please, can I just have more?
More double trigger.
Can I have a little double trigger as a treat?
Double trigger!
It's not working!
There we go.
Hit!
Sparta!
Eat it!
Oh no!
This is Dante's victory jump.
I got that.
So what opened...
Was it the door down here?
Did someone say the door to darkness?
No.
OK.
Dante would totally do that.
Yeah, he would.
You are doing great against these bosses tonight.
Thanks!
Let's save.
I wish I had more Yorbs.
I yearn for the Yorb.
How do I get out of here?
I'm Yorbin'.
Please.
How do I get out of here?
Can I get out?
It's over.
We beat the game.
Oh wait, I see.
There we go.
Wait, what's over here?
I figured it...
There was a Gorb there the whole time.
What's my health like?
Oh we could really use that.
Nice.
OK.
Alright.
It's a gold statue of a knight.
It looks like something was placed here.
Should I use the chalice?
Yes.
Why put the chalice down there if you are just going to place it right back up here?
What's the point?
Do you like Arona?
Like...
Blue Archive Arona?
Yeah, she's my favorite character.
Actually, I think we were there...
She showed off a figure.
I'm pretty sure that's the figure she got when we were together.
I took her to the Blue Archive store.
What would a mint colored orb be called?
Oh wait.
Would a mint colored orb be called a Morb?
Yes.
Oh, OK.
Now it's the other door down here.
Did someone say the door to darkness?
Alright.
Wait,
I thought this was Sparda.
This...is...not Sparda?
Oh, it's not.
Nelo...Nelo...Nelo Angelo.
Sparda is your dad?
Yeah, but he looks just like him.
See?
For cool.
For cool moves.
OK, just because someone says that their dad is dead in a video game or anime or any type of fictional media...
Never means that it is true.
Don't spoil the big secret.
Oh yeah, if there are spoilers...
Don't tell me.
Yeah, just because someone is just like...
Doesn't mean he is actually dead.
I've learned from anime and game.
I have.
The real Sparda was the friends we made along the way.
Yeah, this is my first time playing, so no spoilers everybody.
Go to the deck and head to the captain's cabin.
Should I buy stuff?
Oh, we are so close for the air hike.
I want it.
Damien, thank you!
Thank you so much for the summertime!
Really appreciate it.
Did no one tell you Dante's last name was Skywalker?
Mr. Slider, welcome back!
Just save for air hike.
OK.
I want it.
Alright, go to the deck.
Mission start!
Oh...
I will become a ghost here because I'll die so many times.
The controls are based on the normal mode.
Wait, what's the easy mode then?
I wonder.
Oh no, any like mid 2000's and before...
Swimming levels are absolute hell.
Any game that had a swimming level in the mid 2000's and prior are just the worst experiences ever.
Nobody likes them.
It turns out Nero Angelo is a big boss who survived Outer Heaven.
This was a doppelganger, not a venom snake.
Wait, am I supposed to... I never learned that name though, right?
The Nero Angelo?
They never... Nelo?
Wait, Nelo Angelo?
Nero... Nelo... Nelo...
I did.
When did they tell me?
Nelo.
It's in the menu.
I set it in a loading screen.
Alright, I gotta concentrate, you guys.
I gotta read this.
Okay, so whatever check means, but also I can shoot and stuff with the RB.
Y quickly changes the view to the direction that the left stick is being pressed.
Okay, you cannot use your devil trigger.
And A is to swim.
I hope I don't have an oxygen meter.
In the same menu as the inventory, you have an enemy...
Enemy?
What is a beast?
Oh my gosh, Nicholas.
No oxygen meter.
Okay, thank you.
These trains are always fun to listen to.
Listen in on while I wrap up my shift.
Oh, a dawn!
Thank you!
Good luck with the end of your shift.
Change directions up, down, but they're inversed.
Okay.
You know what?
Let's just go for it.
Let's just...
That was early.
Oh, whoops.
Nice.
Hello.
Too good at this game.
Money,
money, money.
Welcome to the membership!
Thank you!
Money, money, money.
How much money did I get?
I wish there was a practice area.
Like here is where you can practice swimming without... with no risk.
Orbeez.
Oh gosh!
Okay, inversed.
Oh my god.
That's inversed.
Sorry guys, it's going to take me a second to get used to.
Okay, we can go in here.
Ah!
Shoot!
I looked the wrong way!
How do I fight?
My gun!
Wait, where is my gun?
Hello?
My weapon is not weaponing.
Shoot!
I'm trying!
I'm pressing RB and pressing the button, but it's not working.
Maybe I have to have the... this equipped instead?
You don't have a water gun yet.
Wait, what does that mean?
What are you talking about?
A water gun.
Wait, there is a water gun?
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
You need a special gun?
What?
Is there anything up here perhaps that I can peruse before I venture into this horrible landscape?
That is.
Come on, let me check out the pirate show.
No?
Okay.
Okay, just swim past him.
Damn lizard people.
Swim up after you enter the ship.
Okay, thank you.
I don't like this.
Okay, I'm gonna equip my other gun for now again.
Yes.
Okay.
Can I get him from in the water?
No?
What is that?
What's that sound?
There is nothing in the treasure box except seashells.
What if I bust it open?
The only underwater level I could ever tolerate was Ninja Gaiden 2 just because it gave you a Gatlin harpoon for defense.
Only worked underwater.
That, yeah.
That would make it more tolerable, I believe.
I... remember just...
Oh my gosh!
Give me a second to...
Oops.
Now I'm gonna have to redo this again.
No!
Absolute!
Perform an S-Rank combo using Alistair!
Guys, I'm killing it!
I'm killing it!
Yippee!
Water gun.
Needle gun.
Only weapon that can be used underwater.
Thank you.
Oh wait, will it... I guess I'll equip it when I'm down there.
What's in here?
Oh, I didn't.
Nothing's in here, I guess.
It will auto equip?
Oh, ok, perfect.
Thanks guys!
Thanks for always helping me out.
This looks like it'd be turnable, doesn't it?
Like, for some reason the way it's...
It looks like it's turnable.
Is this a room?
Guys, I need to use the little ghostie's room.
Swimming with Minto makes the jank controls okay!
I have to use the little ghostie's room.
Please forgive me.
Do you forgive me?
Do you forgive Minto?
Ok, yeah.
Remember to wash your hands.
I always wash my hands.
I'm not... I'm not like another bug.
Oh, Elfriede!
I'm so sorry, I missed your donut earlier.
You have now unsubscribed from Devil May Cry Fun Facts.
You have now subscribed to Metal Gear Fun Facts.
Did you know that Meryl technically originally appeared in Police Nights?
It's so funny.
I love it though.
I love when people tag me in stuff on Twitter.
I get so many tags from people.
Like recently they announced Gengar headphones.
I got maybe like 15 tags from people.
But I don't mind it.
I know, sorry, I got a little snippy earlier with the facts.
It's just, you know, I was like, so sick of seeing it.
But for other things, you know, I just know you guys are excited and excitable about wanting to share things about the game.
And people will tag me in stuff about Metal Gear.
And, you know, even if I've seen it, it's just, you know, I'm like, you guys are thinking of me.
Even if you think that I've seen something before, like at least on Twitter or whatever, you can feel free to tag me or whatever.
If you're just like, oh my gosh, Minto would like these Gengar headphones.
I would.
Every time I saw them, I was like, they're so cute.
But it was funny and 100% warranted.
But yeah, it's so funny because sometimes people will be like, did you know this Metal Gear thing?
And sometimes I don't know, there's not, you know, I don't know everything.
But at this point, I think I know a lot of stuff.
Did you know this game was originally gonna be MGS4?
Thank God it wasn't.
You can beat us up sometimes too.
Oh, I will.
I do.
I wonder how many tagged you for that big boss grave saluting statue.
A lot.
But also sometimes I'll learn something and then I forget about it.
And then someone will tell me again and I'll be like, oh yeah, that's such a cool fact and I forgot about it.
I don't think I'll ever forget though that this game was supposed to be Resident Evil 4 though.
Never.
I'll be seeing the light, like going to heaven.
I'll be like, oh my gosh, I've fulfilled all my...
Gosh, I forgot ghost terminology.
The things that I wanted...
What's the word?
The things that keep me here.
Unfinished business.
Yeah, oh my gosh, I was just watching Casper the other day too.
I've finished all my unfinished business.
It's time that I can see the light.
I can move on.
And then right before... When I'm seeing my afterlife flash before my eyes...
The last thing that I see will be...
DMC was supposed to be Resident Evil 4.
Dies.
Well, not dies, goes to heaven.
The live action Casper?
Yeah!
You know how like... Oh my gosh, it's kind of messed up.
What do you mean fake ghost?
I'm a real ghost.
Thank you.
Thank you for the prank.
Yeah, and like the Casper live action is kind of messed up.
They create the machine that can turn ghosts back into humans and then they're going to use it on Casper.
And then there's the lady that's just like, I turned myself into a ghost and I'm going to become all powerful.
But she doesn't know about the unfinished business.
And then they're like, what about your unfinished business?
If you're a ghost, what's your unfinished business?
And she's just like, what?
I have no unfinished business.
And then she's like, blah!
And she gets sucked into the light.
And she's like, no!
You guys tricked me!
And then the girl's dad is a ghost and I'm like, that just means that he died.
And they had to use the machine to make him human again.
I'm like, this is so sad for Casper.
That movie was so weird.
It was really weird.
Did you have a crush on Casper as a kid?
I don't think so.
I don't remember.
It's kind of... I don't know.
It's like weird.
I don't know.
Is it supposed to be not an okaeri nasaimase?
Yeah.
Okaeri nasaimase.
Okay.
I genuinely thought you were going to say that the last thing you would ever see was going to be DMCA.
Which is most YouTube channels last night.
So many of my streams will become non-monetized because of some arbitrary song in it.
I even lowered the volume for Way to Fall when I finished MGS3 and it still got copyright claimed.
Or just sometimes it picks on stuff.
But it's okay.
It's just ad revenues.
Whatever.
Unfinished business.
Big boss rank MGS2.
At least that will be mine.
I salute you.
For real?
Yeah.
It's okay.
It's fine.
So...
I remember that movie.
The scene where he dances with the main girl and he's alive.
I remember thinking, wow, he was pretty handsome before he died.
I keep seeing these TikToks of kids nowadays watching Casper.
And their reactions to seeing human Casper.
And it's so cute!
But I'm like...
I'm like...
I feel like I look better as a ghost.
I don't wanna...
I mean, sorry, Casper was like an egg, but that's not me.
I'm like...
I don't... I... I...
I look better as a ghost.
I don't need to be human.
I think.
You're also anime.
Casper was animated too!
You're not an egg.
You guys...
With my...
New form coming.
My...
My rigor.
They were like...
Hey, here's a test.
And... Oh, sorry.
I also left it so you could be bald.
And I'm like, should I...
Should I ask them to keep it?
Would you guys want to see a bald...
I could actually look like Casper.
Yes?
That was a good one, Alizora.
Bald, you want to see?
I'll probably never use it ever.
The difference between you and Casper is Casper is a friendly ghost.
I'm pretty friendly.
I'm doing that thing where like, you know...
That girly thing where you flutter your eyelashes.
Is it working?
Okay, let me go to the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Gone version.
BRB.
Oh, it's all the way up there.
I'll be fast.
I'm back!
Cool to see Mint get a stylish combo.
Two times today!
For you guys, I got it first with the...
The...
The thing.
I can't remember.
The thing!
What was it?
Oh my gosh.
I got... No, my fists.
My fists, my fists.
Minto Gaming.
Alright.
Let's continue.
I do want to check up here real quick.
Even though we'll have to fight the guys again.
I guess that's... Oh wait, what's this?
Oh, we're up top!
Wow!
This is so exciting.
I love... Oh my gosh, ghost ships are so cool.
What is this?
What is this thing anyway?
Oh, this is where the fire of the spirit is lit.
But right now it's sealed and can't be lit.
The One Piece.
I guess we'll come back here.
I mean, obviously.
The sword... Wait!
It's locked shut.
There's something written.
I am the ship that carries the wandering souls on the brink of the underworld.
Yarg!
Protect the ship and you shall be given the fire of Saint Elmo!
No way!
Oh no, no, no.
Bye!
Where are they?
You exited.
Yeah, on purpose.
Hell no!
Am I gonna fight that guy and then have to do it again?
Wait.
Like I have to go back down here, do I not?
Do I not have to go back down here, right?
I think I killed him.
I mean, I figured since I had to kill him, right?
Maybe I don't have to go back down here.
What was the point of getting the gun if I don't have to come back down here?
Wait, what was the point of getting the gun and...
What?
Huh?
Later?
Okay.
Oh, for later.
Next mission there is more swimming!
And me.
We got him.
I have to fight him?
Aw man.
Okay.
Here...
Air attack on Ifrit is pretty good against the Scythe guy if I remember correctly.
Use Ifrit's jump kick on the boss on the deck.
Do I?
Oh, I have the jump kick.
Jump kick was... Wait.
Jump kick was... Hold on.
Let's practice.
It was...
Oh, wait.
Like, wait.
Oh, jump.
Oh, that?
That?
Death Scythe is easier than his cousin Death Scissors.
I hate all of them.
Okay.
That's the one.
If he'll come down here...
It's the only move I got!
Oh, wait.
Where is he?
Oh.
It's the only
move I... It's the only move I got!
Oh, come on.
Over here please.
Oh, we did it!
You guys!
What was that crashing sound?
What was that?
Who broke something?
It wasn't me.
Wow, this ship is huge.
Nice.
Oh gosh.
Oh golly.
I'm walking the plank.
Why did I say it with that accent?
I don't know.
Wait.
Oh, dang it.
I want to go to the... Oh my gosh, I can see a little orb all the way over there.
Protect the ship.
Okay.
Maybe from this side it will be better.
All the way to the tippy top.
Oh my gosh, there is even things here.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Is that orb near or far?
Well, at least we know there is a thing up here.
Oh, I think I got water on my dress.
I was like, what?
What is that feeling?
Near... far... I can't tell at all.
This is the spirit thing.
Right now it's sealed and can't be lit.
Okay.
I can't tell...
Oh, thank goodness.
My heart sunk for a second.
I was like, what if there is fall damage?
Wait, can I go to the tippy top here?
Okay.
Kingdom hearts as run.
Fall damage in a DMC game.
I don't know.
I don't know anything.
Okay.
Let's try the other... Oh, let's try... Oh my goodness.
How do I... Oh.
Okay, we got that.
Nice.
Very cool.
Very good.
And up.
Oh, he used the ladder.
Up.
Nice.
Tiny Rorb.
Do it for the Rorb.
Did I ever stream Kingdom Hearts?
No.
I just played it a lot as a kid.
Like an obscene amount I played that game.
So I always reference it.
Oh gosh.
Sorry, I keep referencing it today.
I don't know why.
I guess I'm in just a Kingdom Hearts mood or something.
Oh, there we go.
Is that...
Is that all of them?
I don't feel like I got all of them.
Wait, oh.
Oh my gosh, there is some on the little tips.
No.
You guys, I have to get them.
I won't feel complete otherwise.
Ok, over here.
Do it for the one Rorb.
Was there anything else to do here?
Or rather, anything else to loot?
Did I get all the stuff?
I think I did.
I think we are good.
One Rorb.
What if I just jumped here?
Ok.
Alright.
I think you got it.
Where is that one?
You sneaky.
Speaking of Kingdom Hearts and underwater levels, at least we know this level could be worse.
So true.
The one Rorb is real.
One Rorb.
One, one, one Rorb.
Is this next?
It's the next one, I think.
I got this one.
Wait, where is it?
Eh?
Nice.
It's on the lower pole.
I thought that's where I got the other one though.
Is it here?
No.
Wait, one more down?
Oh, like maybe all the way down?
Where the hell is this Rorb?
Guys, there is no other pole.
The tip of the spike.
Wait, do I go up here?
There is no spike.
I went on the middle pole.
This one...guys, I've been here three times.
Unless I jump.
The middle, middle.
This one over here.
I understand.
What?
Secret Rorbs.
Wait, is it up higher?
Can we get much higher?
Ok.
That has to be all of them.
Otherwise I'm insane.
Otherwise I'm gonna actually become the Joker.
Ok.
We got them all.
Ok, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Sorry guys.
My loot instincts.
Every Rorb counts, ok?
I thought I was gonna have to do that.
Lucky me.
Are we going to the underworld?
Oh my gosh.
Dante, hold on!
Oh my god.
Yo-ho, yo-ho, a pirate's life for me.
Shubat!
Yeah, oh my gosh.
The one piece happening right now.
Is this ship sturdy?
Ok, we're leaving the castle.
Bye!
Oh no, no, no.
No, no ambush.
Oh, this is messed up.
Don't blow up my...
No!
Ok, wait.
Wait, I messed up.
This is the one I want.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, oh my gosh.
What is happening?
What is going on?
Oh, what the hell?
What is happening actually?
What is going on?
I can't tell at all.
What is happening?
Please, I can't see anything.
This angle is horrible, horrid.
Horrid and rude.
Switch back to ebony and ivory.
No, I think it's ok.
What is this thing though?
Do I shoot it?
Do I kill it?
Maybe I do.
Ok, hold on.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Ok, ok, ok.
I don't...
Oh, I jumped, I jumped, but it didn't really...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I don't like this.
You guys, this is really... I hate this.
Why are all these fights getting so bad?
All these fights are getting so mean!
What is going on?
I'm not even doing anything.
This is useless.
So useless.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
Why?
Why am I dying?
Ouch.
No, please, I just had a good angle.
Stop hurting me!
How do I stop this thing?
I went off.
I went off the ride!
I don't like this ride!
Please!
Oh my god.
No, no.
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no.
Devil, devil, devil trigger!
Devil trigger!
Ok, that's not enough.
That's not enough, I think.
Oh, there we go.
Just destroy.
Just go!
Dante, just go!
Dante!
Oh my god.
No.
No, no, please.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think I'm in trouble.
Guys.
Literally...
1 HP.
Oh, let's go to the door.
Oh my god.
Fight Griffin a second time and prevail.
Thanks.
I don't know.
B rank!
B for barely made it.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, Garlamald!
I just saw your Akatono earlier.
Add revenue.
No!
Thank you!
I don't need add revenue.
Collect 10,000 red orbs!
Yippee!
Wait a second.
No.
Let's do this one, because if I have just 1 HP...
I'm gonna be in trouble.
Next mission!
Mission 13.
Find an exit and escape from the ship.
Okay.
Yeah, we saved the orb.
So true.
Oh wait!
I forgot to...
I can get air hike!
Let's get air hike!
Double jump, baby!
Who are you?
Wait.
Who is this?
Wow!
I wanna talk to...
Oh, it's a skeleton of the captain.
Strangely, it appears as though there is a slight smile on his expression.
Dante, that's a skeleton.
It's a logbook.
Exciting.
Okay, Dante.
We don't need your sass.
Oh, smiley?
Thank you.
No spoilers, guys.
No spoilers.
Staff of Hermes.
It's decorated with two snakes coiled onto the staff.
Is this timed?
Wait, I can breathe underwater.
Exciting.
And I have... Wait, I just got double... Oh, we're sinking.
Sorry, I didn't mean to destroy your ship or anything.
Hey, buddy.
Why is this music like this?
It's making me feel a little stressed.
Why is it so excitable?
Is this...
Dude...
Oh my gosh.
The guy and his baby.
Okay, I guess I'm going.
Hold on, I'm just gonna...
Water pressure is too strong and it won't open.
There's got to be another way out.
Sorry, man.
Oh, the windows.
Windows are always a good way out.
Just kidding.
I'm looking, guys.
I'm looking.
Let's see.
These decorations are so awesome.
Are we venting?
Oh, I see it.
I'll be honest, I thought that was a fireplace.
I think
I'm not very good at aiming.
Here I go.
Traveling forward.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I killed him.
Nice.
Oh my god, no.
Okay, we did it?
Okay, cool.
Anything else exciting in here?
Anything?
Oh, come on.
I want to check.
Stop, stop, stop.
Stop, stop, Dante.
I want to check this treasure chest.
See?
Check the treasure chest.
Is there a guy downstairs?
Was it...
Which thing opened?
The one over here?
I believe.
This one?
Did this one open?
Or was it this one down here?
I don't know.
I'm in hell.
Try both.
Please!
Why can't I see you guys?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, why is it turning that way?
I don't understand this mechanic at all.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my god, it's right behind me, isn't it?
No!
Oh my god, no!
I don't know where I'm going.
I think I'm...
Leaving.
Why do I have to press Y to change my face direction?
It's horrible.
B for...
Better get out of there.
This is so silly.
Oh my gosh, that was episode... Sorry, mission 13.
Good job, Minto.
Thanks, Rudy.
Thanks for a whole month.
B for bullshit.
So true.
Oh man, B for busted camera controls.
So true!
B for boingy boof.
And that, my friends, is definitely the answer.
Boingy boof.
So what?
We're at...
We have less than...
We're over halfway.
Oh, I guess from last mission we were over halfway, huh?
So...
Let's save.
Oh wait, did I just save?
Oops, whatever.
Next mission!
Great progress.
Oh, no, there's more?
They're like, hey, don't you want to go back in and do more of that?
I see you, Rarm.
Looks like almost a trap.
Is this not where we started?
Piece of...
Oh, we must go in for the blorb.
Blorb, blorb, blorb.
Blorb fragment.
Oh yeah, now we can finally use the air hike.
There's a blorb in the captain's cabin if you go back.
I think I'm okay.
It's okay.
But thank you.
Insert chat message.
Thanks, Alvin!
Yeah, I think I'm okay with going...
They spent dev time on the underwater section.
By God, you're going to experience it.
This feels like exactly where we came from.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I killed him.
Oh, please.
Get him.
There we go.
Double jump, but I'm in these tiny little rooms.
There's a treasure here, but there's nothing that can be used as weapons.
What do you mean by that?
Dante, your brain!
Dante is just like, I don't care about money.
Holy water!
But there was a treasure in there!
There we go.
What's the mission anyway?
Oh, mission 14.
Deep darkness and towering mountains.
Go to the surface and head for the Colosseum.
I'm scared of the Colosseum, you guys!
I'm scared!
Oh geez!
You should be.
I don't like that.
Do I just run for it?
And then it looks like spikes are probably going to come out from the ground.
Cardio time.
I feel like the camera angle is really going to make this a tedious task.
I made
it.
It doesn't turn, right?
I mean...
Oh, what's this?
The iron fence is blocking the way.
Oh, we're back.
Oh gosh.
Okay, so I'm guessing... wait.
Oh god.
Oh no, it's going to activate as soon as I grab this, isn't it?
Oh gosh!
So I probably have to get to the iron fence.
I'm guessing this is maybe the key, perhaps?
There's something written.
The resonating emblem shall undo the seal of the shield.
The emblem shield.
Where was that?
Long time ago.
A birdy area.
A small shield, the emblem has the same shape as that of those sealing the doors of the Colosseum.
Oh boy.
The skeleton's arm appears to be a lever of some sort.
Don't, don't do it.
Dante, don't, don't, don't do it.
Should I turn the lever?
Do I have to?
Dante, you have like a fist.
You've broken down walls before.
Dante, it's just an iron door.
Dante, just use your fist.
Hello Mint.
Hi HHPoint, thank you for six runs.
I'm gonna hate this.
The booby trap has been...
Activated!
Oh, these are way worse than I expected.
Oh my gosh.
Boy, this is way worse than I expected.
Run Dante, run!
I think I'm going the wrong way.
Oh wait, no I'm not.
We made it!
Ok, we're fine.
Wasn't so bad actually after all.
Who's here?
What's here?
What's around here?
Take a shower Dante.
What was that?
What is this?
There's something in here.
Grab it Dante.
Dante, grab whatever that is.
What is that?
Grab it.
Can't tell.
Oh!
Holy water.
Ok.
My, oh!
My depth perception is once again...
Firmly grasping.
Oh,
oopsie.
Hold on.
Please, Dante.
Can you grab that?
These are terrible jokes about ghosts and booby traps here.
I have this double jump for what?
I can't even...
I can't even make it!
Please!
I have this jump for what?
Wait, maybe I have to like...
Is this like a little bit higher here?
Oh, ok.
Maybe I have to go to like...
Oh, I see it.
Oh my gosh.
Please, camera angle.
This game hates us.
This game hates you so much.
No, Dante.
Dante, no!
Stop jumping down, Dante.
Oh my gosh.
Can't even just jump.
Your feet are so slippery.
Dante, stop jumping down.
Seriously.
I'm not even doing that.
He like just automatically turns around and says...
Nah.
I think there is a platform.
You can't see in front of it like where the camera is.
Do I go from...
Wait, I can't see where I'm jumping.
Maybe if I go from like here.
I give up.
Stinger jump?
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
How do I stinger jump?
I just keep doing...
You can use stinger for a longer jump.
No, I want to practice.
No, I'm trying to practice, you guys.
Stinger jump is when you stinger while facing a ledge.
Oh, so I have to do it from the ledge.
Okay.
If I can get back up here.
Okay, there we go.
Wait, so...
Okay.
I can't even aim this, you guys.
No, I give up.
I give up.
It's not worth it.
Wait, so I think I do have to go that direction though.
Back where the blorb was.
Now you know how to stinger jump.
Oh, no, that's not a... Wait, how do I get out of here?
Hello?
Oh, over here.
Just kidding.
This teeny tiny little doorway.
Oh, shit.
No, no.
Fuck me.
No, no, no!
Okay, let's go...
Back down here.
Oh, I can't.
I can't go... Oh, here we go.
Wait, the dog!
Wait!
Oh, wait, I should...
Oh, sorry, I keep doing this.
You know what?
It's fine.
I can handle the dog.
I don't know about two of them, but...
Okay.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do...
Oh, shoot.
Maybe I can't handle two of them.
Oh, I don't know if I can handle two of them.
Oh my God.
Wait, I don't know if I can handle two of them, you guys.
Oh, shit.
I don't know if I can handle two of them!
Ahh, I don't know if I can handle two of them!
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
No, no, no!
Stop, stop, stop!
Oh, I'm dead.
They really got me good.
How am I supposed to know who's gonna ambush me?
What the...
Oh my god, who are you?
I'm just gonna leave.
Hi.
Oh my god, they follow.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is all I got!
Wait, do I have to spend money on this?
Is this one of those spend money...
You mean I could've left this whole time?
No way.
Wait, but now I can explore the area maybe.
I could've left this whole time.
What else is here?
Tree.
Oh, what's that?
Wait, there's a little room.
What's this?
Is this the free...
You can switch?
Yeah, I know, I'm just silly sometimes.
I know, I'm just silly sometimes.
Sometimes I get so flustered, I press pause.
I panic and I press pause.
And then I'm like, well, if I'm here, I might as well switch.
I'm gonna go to the other one.
Even though it costs money...
It's pay to win, right?
Usually that's how these things kind of work.
They don't even ask.
They're not even like, do you want to use 200 red orbs?
They're like, oh, nah, we're stealing your money.
Silly.
Oh, it's
another pay to win.
Let's farm money here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they never stop.
They don't stop coming.
And they stop coming.
Dante, it helps when you...
It helps when you actually go up there.
Okay, that's where we came...
Wait, is that where we came from?
We are...
This is where we came from.
Anything over
here?
Secret?
Any secrets over here?
I know your game, Devil May Cry.
Devil may give me my money.
That's more like it.
Oh shit, let's leave.
We took too long!
Go, go!
Don't worry about them out there.
You have unsealed it.
Look at Dante here.
Look at him looking so smug.
Refund a bit.
Yeah, actually.
He looks so smug.
What?
A D?
As in...
Done right?
Damn girl, you devil hunter.
What?
A D?
I killed those guys so stylishly.
Do I have any orbs left?
I don't even know.
Wait, what?
That was 14?
15?
Guys, I think I'm gonna call it here.
Maybe next time we play, I will endurance...
The next 10?
We'll see, we'll see.
I think I'll call it here and do the whole rest of the game.
The last bit.
Are you gonna call it on a D?
Because it hurt my pride.
My self esteem.
What's the next mission number?
15.
Number 15.
Yeah.
Oh my god, I think I'm getting pretty good at this game though.
What do you guys think?
I think I'm gaming a little bit.
Spank!
Thanks for the attack gifter!
Thank you.
Only 8 missions left.
Oh, 8?
Oh, for some reason my brain was thinking 10.
Yeah, 8.
Oh, it's 23.
Yes, 23.
Beat a lot of big bosses.
Great progress, great combos.
You are getting so much better at this game.
I remember the final boss being brutal, but you can do it.
We can do it, I believe.
You can definitely finish next stream.
I think so.
I think even if it takes me longer, I'm okay with going longer, obviously.
I'll probably plan it for...
I kind of have my next couple of weeks planned out a little bit.
I will find a time where I can stream for longer.
You are progressing too fast for me to get up and get a snack.
Could you be worse?
Have faith that your streamer will be good all the time!
So...
I'll figure out a time.
I'll figure out a time that I can endure it.
Tomorrow, I will be seeing my family.
But also we'll have a very short stream.
Watching the idol EN debuts.
So there will be that.
And...
Yeah, it will be quite a short stream.
But tomorrow I have stuff to do.
So I wasn't even really going to stream tomorrow.
But it ended up being that way.
But that's okay.
Take care, man.
Thanks, chat!
Wait, thanks, Don.
Thank you for the DMC stream.
The cutest devil hunter is also the cutest.
Oh, sorry, wait.
The story...
AI summary says chat is excited for the sequel.
Satan might weep.
Okay, thank you guys!
Thank you!
And I hope you guys have a great rest of your night.
We did a lot of fisting today.
And I think it's a certain fister's birthday.
So maybe go show her some appreciation and some love.
Or Matara is doing her sub-a-thon on Twitch television.
So you can go watch that as well.
It will be all night, baby.
Thank you!
Minto is cute and gaming.
Good gaming, Minto!
You are getting better and better.
Thank you!
Pirate505, thank you!
I had the wildest dream today.
An old wise man came to me and said, Did you know that DMC1 was originally supposed to be a different game?
And then I woke up.
Man, I really wanted to know what he was going to tell me.
Thank you for the donos!
Thank you for all the superchats!
Thank you!
We are rating Gigi or Mata.
Whoever you want to watch.
Go watch whoever you want to watch.
I'm sure there are other Vtubers, other streamers streaming as well.
In fact, I am positive there are.
So, go!
Or just go and relax and enjoy the rest of your night.
It's Friday, baby!
It's the weekend!
Enjoy your weekend.
Hopefully you get lots of rest.
Don't forget to hydrate.
Don't forget to...
Don't forget to stand up and stretch and do all that good stuff.
No, there are no others, just Minto.
Going to Japan for a bit will hit up at least one maid cafe.
Say more!
You have to do more than one.
More than one.
And then, of course, don't forget, Minto's 3.0 is in...
12 days.
Wait.
Yes?
Is it the 18th?
Oh, wait.
No.
13 days.
12 days?
12 days of Christmas?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12...
13!
13 days.
Yeah.
Okay!
Awesome Minto, everybody!
Thank you!
Otsu Friday!
Came back from work late, but just got to relax with Minto's stream.
Otsu!
If you guys had a hard week, hopefully...
The weekend can wash away all of your stress.
And relax.
Bye bye!
Itterasshai!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
I really appreciate it!
Bye bye!